First of all, is your last named pronounced Ivv-ins or Eye-vins?
首先，你的姓氏读作“Ivv-ins”还是“Eye-vins”？
Eye-vins.
Eye-vins。
And what's your correct title now?
现在你正式的头衔是什么？
Astronaut.
宇航员。
Like, on your business card, it says, "astronaut?"
也就是说，你的名片上印的是“宇航员”？
It actually does.
确实印着。
That is the most glamorous thing I've ever heard.
这是我听过最令人向往的事情了。
OK, here's a question. We've got 95 active-duty astronauts in our country, but they almost never go into space anymore. Some years, there's just one shuttle mission. The most we ever do is three or four. So if you're an astronaut, OK, you show up for work at Johnson Space Flight Center every morning. What do you do all day?
好，问个问题。我国有95名现役宇航员，但他们几乎不再进入太空了。有些年份只有一次航天飞机任务。我们一年最多也只进行三次或四次。所以，如果你是一名宇航员，每天早上到约翰逊航天中心上班，你整天都在做什么？
Monday's are the days from hell. So Monday, I go to meetings all day long.
周一简直是地狱。周一我得开一整天的会。
Marsha Ivins is a veteran of five space missions between 1990 and 2001.
玛莎·伊文斯（Marsha Ivins）是1990年至2001年间五次太空任务的资深宇航员。
We have the astronaut office meeting. We have the staff meeting. Because I support the new constellation program, they have a staff meeting.
我们有宇航员办公室会议。我们有员工会议。因为我支持新的星座计划，所以他们也有员工会议。
We've got to sit in a lot of conference rooms.
我们得在会议室里坐很久。
Chris Cassidy was chosen to be an astronaut in 2004.
克里斯·卡西迪（Chris Cassidy）于2004年入选成为宇航员。
And sometimes I find that tedious. And as a new guy astronaut, we go to a lot of those meetings.
有时我觉得很枯燥。作为一名新手宇航员，我们得参加很多这样的会议。
I would say the worst part is probably the meetings.
我觉得最糟糕的部分可能就是开会。
Cady Coleman flew space missions in 1995 and, most recently, 1999.
凯迪·科尔曼（Cady Coleman）曾于1995年执行过太空任务，最近一次是在1999年。
There is also the paperwork. When you work for the government, you have to go to a security refresher and ethics refresher.
还有文书工作。为政府工作时，你必须参加安全培训和道德规范培训。
OK, so it's the day you get back from a shuttle mission, are there special weird forms that you have to fill out on that day?
那么，从航天飞机任务回来那天，是不是有一些特别奇怪的表格必须在那天填完？
Well, there is a travel voucher. You know, we work for the government, all of us. And there is some government thing that says, when you're traveling, you will be paid for just the fact that you are gone from home, and there must be something you had to buy.
嗯，有差旅凭证。你知道，我们都为政府工作。政府规定，当你出差时，你会因为离家而获得补贴，而且你肯定买过什么东西。
Oh yeah, the $3.50 a day thing.
哦，对，那个每天3.5美元的规定。
It's $3.50 a day?
是每天3.5美元吗？
I think that's the government, what they call meals and incidentals rate.
我想那是政府所谓的膳食和杂费标准。
So if I'm going to Washington, DC to go to NASA headquarters, it authorizes me the mode of transportation, you know, commercial air, or train, or taxi, or whatever when I'm there. So when we go to space, we get travel orders that authorize us to go from Houston to the Kennedy Space Center to Earth orbit and return.
所以如果我要去华盛顿特区去NASA总部，它会批准我的交通方式，比如民航、火车、出租车或者其他当地交通工具。所以当我们去太空时，我们领到的差旅令授权我们从休斯顿前往肯尼迪航天中心，再到地球轨道，最后返回。
Wait, and is there a place on it where it says, like, taxi, jet, space shuttle? Like, is that an actual box you fill in?
等等，上面有没有一栏写着“出租车、喷气式飞机、航天飞机”？这真的是你可以填写的选项吗？
It's government air.
是政府专机。
Government air?
政府专机？
It's government air. And then lodging is provided, transportation is provided, meals are provided.
是政府专机。而且住宿、交通和餐食都是由政府提供的。
The astronauts all have offices, three or four of them to a room, on the sixth floor of a nondescript office building. They do some public speaking. Cady, for example, had just talked to a ninth grade biology class. Chris had welcomed the Farm Credit Bank of Texas Annual Stockholders Meeting to Houston just a couple of hours before our interview. If they have a mission coming up, they train all the time, but they almost never have a mission coming up.
宇航员都有办公室，一个房间三四个人，位于一栋普通办公楼的六楼。他们偶尔会进行公开演讲。比如，凯迪刚刚给九年级的生物课讲过话。克里斯在接受我们采访前几个小时，刚刚欢迎了得克萨斯农信银行的年度股东大会来到休斯顿。如果他们有任务即将执行，他们就会一直在训练，但他们几乎没有即将执行的任务。
Most of the time they spend on the ground seems to be helping design the gear that's used in space, and teaching others how to use that gear and practicing on that gear. They have to do a lot of studying. It's like grad school, one of them said, the operating systems of the space shuttle.
他们大部分时间在地面上，似乎是在帮助设计太空中使用的装备，教别人如何使用这些装备，并在装备上进行练习。他们必须进行大量的学习。其中一人说，这就像研究生院一样，要学习航天飞机的操作系统。
And once a week, each of them has to practice flying a real jet, which is to say it's like any good job. For all the stuff that's kind of interesting and sort of fun, there's lots of stuff that you just kind of have to get through. Cady and Chris both estimated they spend maybe one day a week doing the things that they really love.
而且每周，他们每个人都必须练习驾驶真正的喷气式飞机，这就是说，这就像任何好工作一样。尽管有很多有趣和好玩的东西，但也有很多不得不完成的事情。凯迪和克里斯都估计，他们每周大约只有一天是在做他们真正热爱的事情。
That is the stuff, like, being physically in a big white spacesuit and getting lowered into a giant swimming pool and practicing spacewalking.
就是那些事情，比如，穿上沉重的白色宇航服，被吊进巨大的游泳池，练习太空行走。
Now, here in civilian life, when we try to say that something's really difficult, we say, well, it's not rocket science. If you're actually in rocket science, what do you say?
在平民生活中，当我们想说某事非常困难时，我们会说“这又不是什么火箭科学”。如果你真的从事火箭科学，你会怎么说？
You say it's not rocket science, the same thing. And everybody laughs about it, just like we are right now.
你会说“这又不是什么火箭科学”，是一样的。大家都会笑，就像我们现在这样。
Here's something else. Many astronauts are just incredible super-achievers. Chris Cassidy was a navy seal. He led operations in the caves on the Afghan-Pakistan border. He was awarded two bronze stars at a presidential unit citation.
还有一件事。许多宇航员都是了不起的成功人士。克里斯·卡西迪曾是一名海豹突击队员。他曾领导阿富汗与巴基斯坦边境洞穴中的军事行动。他被授予了两枚铜星勋章和总统集体嘉奖。
Cady Coleman has a PhD in polymer science. Before she was an astronaut, her official NASA bio says, she used to quote, "synthesize model compounds to investigate the use of organic polymers for third order nonlinear optical applications, such as advanced computers." These are people who are used to accomplishing big, big things. And the main thing they do as astronauts is not go into space. 44 of the 95 astronauts have never been in space. 19 of the astronauts, like Chris Cassidy, aren't even scheduled for a mission. And time is running out on them. The space shuttle is going to stop flying in 2010. And the next space vehicle isn't going to be ready until 2020. Here's Marsha Ivins.
凯迪·科尔曼拥有高分子科学博士学位。在成为宇航员之前，据NASA的官方简历记载，她曾“合成模型化合物，以研究有机聚合物在三阶非线性光学应用中的用途，例如先进计算机。”这些人习惯于成就伟大的事情。而他们作为宇航员所做的主要事情并不是进入太空。95名宇航员中有44人从未进入过太空。像克里斯·卡西迪这样的宇航员中，有19人甚至没有任务安排。他们的时间也快用完了。航天飞机将于2010年停止飞行。而下一代航天飞行器要到2020年才能准备好。下面是玛莎·伊文斯的看法。
Most people are pretty realists about the nature of things now. I was very fortunate to be selected and assigned to flights in an era where you could actually fly every two or three years. That's never going to happen again. The guys that are in the office now realize that they'll be lucky to get one flight in the 10 or 15 years they spend in the office, maybe two. And so, yes, there's a huge level of frustration and it's not just with astronauts, but with the NASA administrator, with the program managers. You look at the moon every night like a big giant tease out there because it's not any closer.
现在大多数人对现状都很务实。我很幸运能在那个还可以每两三年就飞一次的时代被选中并分配飞行任务。这种情况再也不会发生了。现在办公室里的人意识到，他们在办公室待的10到15年里能有一次飞行任务就很幸运了，或许能有两次。所以，是的，这里弥漫着巨大的挫败感，这不仅是在宇航员之间，也包括NASA局长和项目经理们。你每天晚上看着月亮，就像一个巨大的诱惑挂在那儿，因为它并没有变得更近。
And so she does what us non-astronauts do, she gets some of her space exploration on TV.
所以她做了我们这些非宇航员会做的事，通过电视来满足她对太空探索的渴望。
I do watch Battlestar Galactica and Farscape and all of them. I watch them all.
我确实看《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》、《银河迷航》还有那些节目。我全都看。
And what do you think when you see them flying around there in space? What's that like if you're an astronaut?
当你看到他们在太空中飞来飞去时，你在想什么？如果你是宇航员，那是什么感觉？
Hugely jealous. You know, they have left earth orbit. They have left the solar system. They have developed technologies that enable them to do that. So if you want to talk about frustrating, it's like the commercial, where were those cars of the future that you promised us back when I was a kid? Well, where are those spaceships? Where is that? I want that. You know, I made it through my entire career at NASA, where is that? There's frustration for you.
非常嫉妒。你知道，他们已经离开了地球轨道，离开了太阳系。他们开发了能够做到这一点的技术。所以如果你要谈论挫败感，就像那个广告说的，小时候承诺给我们的那种未来汽车在哪里？那么，那些宇宙飞船在哪里？那东西在哪里？我想要那个。你知道，我在NASA度过了整个职业生涯，那东西在哪里？这才是挫败感。
Does it actually remind you in any real way of being in space?
它在现实中真的让你想起在太空中的感觉吗？
Absolutely none.
完全没有。
None, it doesn't?
一点也没有？
Absolutely not. Well, all of those shows assume that there are some sort of magical gravity things, so that when you're in your vehicle, everybody's all walking on the floor. Well, not in our space program. They've got fighter jet flying. They have pointy noses and wings and they make them look like fighters. None of that is any advantage when there is no atmosphere. You don't need a wing. You don't need a pointed nose. You could be a box and have the same maneuverability as you do-- you know, the Borg had it right. They're a big cube. They're perfectly maneuverable, as opposed to the little Star Fighter with a pointed nose and the wings and the engine in the back.
绝对没有。那些剧都假设存在某种魔法重力，所以当你在飞行器里时，所有人都在地板上行走。但在我们的航天计划中可不是这样。它们有战斗机那种飞行方式。它们有尖尖的机头和机翼，让它们看起来像战斗机。当没有大气层时，这些都没什么用。你不需要机翼，也不需要尖头。你可以是个盒子，拥有和它们一样的机动性——你知道，博格人是对的。他们是一个大立方体。他们非常灵活，而不是像那种带着尖头、机翼和后置引擎的小型星际战斗机。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, we have stories of dream jobs and how all those jobs, of course, have certain aspects that turn out to be not so perfectly dreamy.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在节目中，我们将讲述一些关于梦幻工作的故事，以及当然，所有这些工作都有一些事实证明并不那么完美的梦幻之处。
Our show today in four acts. Act One, I'm Not a TV Star, But I Play One on TV. John Hodgman ends up on a dream job that he never even dreamt of himself. Act Two, Show Me the Annuity. In that act, a dream job that you have almost certainly never heard of, unless you have won $1 million in the lottery. Act Three, The Homesick Explorer. Sarah Vowell tells that story. Act Four, Just One Thing Missing, in which a girl is stopped from getting her dream job by one of the most powerful forces on this earth. Stay with us.
我们今天的节目分为四幕。第一幕，“我不是电视明星，但我是在电视里扮演它”。约翰·霍奇曼（John Hodgman）得到了一份他甚至从未梦想过的梦幻工作。第二幕，“让我看看年金”。在这一幕中，有一个你几乎肯定从未听说过的梦幻工作，除非你中了彩票100万美元。第三幕，“思乡的探险家”。莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）讲述那个故事。第四幕，“只缺了一样东西”，讲述一个女孩因地球上最强大的力量之一而无法得到她的梦幻工作。请继续收听。
Act One, I'm Not a TV Star, But I Play One on TV.
第一幕，“我不是电视明星，但我是在电视里扮演它”。
John Hodgman was a magazine writer and he was a contributor to our radio show, and then he started appearing on television. He now appears about twice a month on The Daily Show with Jon Stewart , and he appears about one million times a month on a series of ads for Apple Computers. You've probably seen these ads, one of the most noticeable ad campaigns in the country. There's two guys against a white background, one's a Mac, one's a PC. John is the PC.
约翰·霍奇曼曾是一位杂志撰稿人，也是我们广播节目的投稿人，后来他开始出现在电视上。他现在大约每月两次出现在乔恩·斯图尔特主持的《每日秀》中，并且在大约一百万次的苹果电脑广告系列中出现。你可能见过这些广告，这是全国最引人注目的广告活动之一。背景是纯白的，站着两个人，一个是Mac，一个是PC。约翰扮演的是PC。
At one of our live shows in Los Angeles-- Los Angeles, of course, the epicenter of American television production-- John talked about what it is like to have this strange new job.
在我们洛杉矶的一场现场演出中——洛杉矶当然是美国电视制作的中心——约翰谈到了拥有这份奇怪的新工作是什么感觉。
Good evening. My name is John Hodgman. Thank you for meeting me here in Los Angeles. I've been enjoying getting to know your city of Los Angeles. Until recently, my only experience within LA had been as a child. I had come here in the early '80s with my dad. He was on business. He took me along. And we went to the Universal Studios tour, and this was traumatic.
晚上好。我叫约翰·霍奇曼。感谢大家在洛杉矶与我见面。我一直很享受了解你们洛杉矶这座城市。直到最近，我在这儿唯一的经历还是孩提时代。我小时候曾和父亲来过这里。他当时是来出差的，带上了我。我们去了环球影城的游览项目，那次经历很痛苦。
What happened was we were sitting on some kind of a bench when I was approached by a small human dressed as Charlie Chaplin. At this time in my life, I had very long hair. I was 10 years old, but I had very long hair. It was a really stupid affectation, but the problem was that people routinely thought that I was a girl. And this would lead to occasional embarrassing situations. Double takes as I entered the men's room, for example. Or being expected, say, to kiss Charlie Chaplin on his white powdered cheek.
当时我们坐在某种长椅上，一个扮成卓别林的小人向我走来。我人生那个阶段留着很长的头发。我当时10岁，但我留着长发。这是一种非常愚蠢的虚荣心，但问题是，人们总是以为我是个女孩。这导致了一些偶尔令人尴尬的情况。例如，我走进男厕所时人们回头看我，或者，比如，他们期待我去亲吻卓别林那涂着白粉的脸颊。
And so, after some predictable and annoying cane and bowler hat shenanigans, the moment came. Charlie Chaplin sat next to me and indicated that he was ready for me to kiss him. He waited me out. It was clear what was expected of me and what was going to happen. And finally, I let it happen. So that was my introduction to your city, a traumatic, gender-confused silent comedy date rape.
于是，在一些可预见的、令人恼火的拐杖和圆顶硬礼帽恶作剧之后，时刻到了。卓别林坐在我旁边，示意他等着我亲他。他耐心地等着。显然大家都在期待我会做什么。最终，我顺从了。所以，这就是我与你们城市的第一次接触：一场令人心碎、性别混淆的默剧式的性骚扰。
At the time, I had no idea why someone would expect a complete stranger to want to kiss them on the cheek. But now I understand, because now I am on television. Now my life has glamour.
当时，我完全不知道为什么有人会指望一个完全陌生的人想要亲吻他们的脸颊。但现在我明白了，因为我现在出现在电视上了。现在我的生活有了魅力。
There is an original definition of the word "glamour" that I did not know about until I read fantasy novels. A glamour is a kind of magical spell originally, to where glamour is to surround yourself with a kind of aura that causes people to see you in a different way, to see you as you are not. It's a disguise. And being on television, I've discovered, is sort of like wearing a disguise, one that you didn't necessarily choose to put on, and only other people can actually see it.
“魅力”（Glamour）这个词最初的定义，我在读奇幻小说前并不知道。魅力最初是一种魔法咒语，意指用一种光环包围自己，使人们以不同的方式看待你，看到一个并非真实的你。这是一种伪装。我发现，出现在电视上就像戴着一种伪装，一种你未必选择穿戴，而只有别人才能真正看见的伪装。
Over the past year, I've been trying to make sense of exactly how this all came about. I had written a book and I had been asked to be a guest on The Daily Show . And next I was asked to audition for a series of ads for a computer company. And I got that job, too. And just like that, I was on TV, pretty much by accident.
过去一年里，我一直在试图理清这一切究竟是如何发生的。我写了一本书，并受邀担任《每日秀》的嘉宾。接着我被要求为一家电脑公司的广告系列试镜。我也得到了那份工作。就这样，我几乎是偶然地出现在了电视上。
And as a result, I am an older, and fatter, and more jowly person than most people who are making their careers on TV, who are starting out on television now. Here are some of the words that blogs have used when describing me on television. "The pudgy John Hodgman." The chubby John Hodgman." "Round John Hodgman." "Stout John Hodgman." "Tubby John Hodgman." "Portly John Hodgman" and "Cutie." There's always an outlier. That last one came from a website that includes a regular feature mapping out celebrity sightings in New York City. And in this an anonymous tipster reported accurately that I was taking the B train south from my home in Manhattan. And I remembered this. I remember this exact thing happening. I was on the subway and I was wearing my brown jacket and my brown pants, and a neighbor had earlier said, you know, you look like a UPS guy in that outfit. And I was sort of thinking about that, and a woman got on the subway and sort of looked at me like, I know you. But then she just immediately started typing on her BlackBerry.
结果，与现在那些在电视上开启事业的年轻人相比，我是一个更老、更胖、更有赘肉的人。以下是博客在描述电视上的我时使用的一些词。“胖乎乎的约翰·霍奇曼”、“圆滚滚的约翰·霍奇曼”、“壮实的约翰·霍奇曼”、“矮胖的约翰·霍奇曼”、“丰满的约翰·霍奇曼”以及“可爱”。总是有一个异类。最后一个词来自一个网站，该网站有一个定期发布的专栏，绘制纽约市的名人行踪。在这篇报道中，一位匿名爆料者准确地报告说我正从曼哈顿的家中乘坐B号地铁南下。我记得这件事。我记得这件事准确地发生了。我当时在地铁上，穿着我的棕色夹克和棕色裤子，邻居早些时候曾说：“你知道吗，你穿那身衣服看起来像个UPS送货员。”我当时正思考这个问题，一位女士上了地铁，看着我，仿佛在说：我知道你。但随后她立刻开始在黑莓手机上打字。
And then, a guy got on and did sort of the same kind of double take look. And which one of those people is the anonymous tipster? Which one thinks I am cutie?
然后，一个男人上车，也做了同样的两次回顾。这两个人里，哪一个是那个匿名爆料者？哪一个认为我是“可爱”？
So highly subjectively, the tipster reported that I was cutie. And then, returning once again to accuracy, the tipster reported I was dressed like a UPS man.
所以，主观上，爆料者报道我是“可爱”。然后，再次回到准确性，爆料者报道我穿得像个UPS送货员。
After that these strange brushes with fame, in which I bizarrely was the famous person, started coming about fairly frequently. Dateline, the Radio Shack, Big Y Plaza, Greenfield, Massachusetts, the young guy at the counter asked me to autograph an old receipt that he pulls out of the garbage.
在那次奇怪的名人邂逅之后，也就是我离奇地成为了那个名人之后，这类事件开始频繁发生。在马萨诸塞州格林菲尔德Big Y广场的Radio Shack店里，柜台上的年轻人让我给一张他从垃圾桶里翻出来的旧收据签名。
What are you doing here? He asks in a way that conveys several more questions. What are you doing in Massachusetts? In Greenfield? At Radio Shack? At the Big Y Plaza?
“你在这里做什么？”他问，语气中透着更多的疑问。你在马萨诸塞州做什么？在格林菲尔德？在Radio Shack？在Big Y广场？
I am buying speaker wire, I tell him.
“我在买音箱线，”我告诉他。
The West Side Highway in the 20s, two men in a brown Chrysler pull up alongside my car. When spotted, double thumbs up.
在西侧公路20号附近，两个坐在棕色克莱斯勒车里的人开到我的车边。被发现后，他们给了我双人大拇指。
The Apple Store, SoHo. General storewide freakout.
SoHo区的苹果商店。全店欢腾。
There are waves of double takes as I walk to buy a cable. The store greeter cannot believe it is me. She jumps up and down. The staff starts to play the ads that I'm in on a giant video screen.
当我走去买线时，人们不断地回头确认。店里的接待员不敢相信真的是我。她跳了起来。员工们开始在巨大的屏幕上播放我出演的广告。
Suddenly, I am like a mascot walking around a theme park. I'm Charlie Chaplin at Universal Studios, and everyone is rushing to kiss me.
突然，我就像一个在主题公园走动的吉祥物。我是环球影城的卓别林，每个人都赶着要亲我。
Not long ago, I was spotted at the airport in New York on my way here. A successful looking businessman passed by me as I was waiting in line. He immediately smiled and said, what, no corporate jet for you?
不久前，我在纽约机场被认出来，当时我正要来这里。我排队时，一位看上去很成功的商人在我身边经过。他立刻微笑着说：“怎么，没坐你的公务机？”
Ha ha, I said.
“哈哈，”我说。
Then the businessman said, whatever they're paying you, you ought to tell them, keep the cash and pay you in flights.
然后那个商人说：“不管他们付给你多少钱，你都应该告诉他们，现金省省，直接付给你机票钱。”
Ha ha, I said.
“哈哈，”我说。
Beyond ha ha, I didn't know what to say, really, for two reasons. First, because prior to my being on television, businessmen in airports did not generally ever speak to me, or even see me. Second, I have to say I was a little confused. As best as I could make it out, this businessman's financial plan for me was as follows.
除了“哈哈”，我真的不知道该说什么，原因有两个。第一，在我上电视之前，机场的商人们通常根本不会跟我说话，甚至根本看不见我。第二，我不得不说，我有点困惑。据我所能理解的，这位商人为我规划的财务计划如下。
I should give up all payment for my work and instead, barter my services for free airfare. I wondered if he had taken his own advice. Had he given up his paycheck for a trip around the world? Had he left his family behind, the children he could no longer feed, and the wife who could not understand his weird decision? Did he now spend his days forever ascending and descending, buckling and unbuckling? And now was he trying to trick me, like a fairy in a fable, into joining his strange, lonely, floating world?
我应该放弃所有工作的报酬，转而用我的服务换取免费机票。我不知道他是否遵循了自己的建议。他是否放弃了薪水去进行环球旅行？他是否抛下了家庭，留下了他再也养不起的孩子，还有那个无法理解他古怪决定的妻子？他现在是否每天都在无休止地登机降机，扣上和解开安全带？他现在是在像寓言里的仙女一样，试图欺骗我进入他那个奇怪、孤独、漂浮的世界吗？
Still, I said, ha ha. In a way, that said, that's a good idea. Because I almost instinctively wanted to please him even though he was clearly insane.
即便如此，我还是说，“哈哈”。这是一种表示“这真是个好主意”的态度。因为我几乎本能地想要取悦他，尽管他显然是个疯子。
Only much later, like, weeks later, would I consider a different explanation for his behavior, that the businessman was starstruck. He knew me from TV, he wanted to make a connection, and said the first thing that came to his head, a very, very bad business idea that made no sense. And I had to consider for the first time the possibility that I didn't need to please him, the successful businessman was trying to please me.
直到很久以后，也就是几周后，我才考虑对他这种行为做出另一种解释，即这位商人只是见到明星太激动了。他通过电视认识我，想和我建立某种联系，于是脑子里蹦出了第一个主意，一个非常非常糟糕、完全讲不通的商业想法。我第一次考虑到，我根本不需要取悦他，是这位成功的商人试图取悦我。
Not to complain, but this has been something of a difficult adjustment in my life. When you are in your 20s, it seems inevitable, somehow, that you will be on television, or an astronaut, or the president. It is hard-wired into every gland, this ambition to be known and renowned. And then, of course, you grow older, pudgier, stouter, more portly.
不是在抱怨，但这对我的生活来说是一个困难的调整。当你20多岁的时候，你会觉得，无论如何，你迟早会出现在电视上，或者成为一名宇航员，或者是总统。那种想要被人知晓、名扬天下的野心是根植在每个腺体里的。然后，当然，你变老了，更胖了，更壮了，更臃肿了。
Then, just when you've discarded the last shred of a shred of a shred of the fantasy of, say, being an astronaut, to then have someone knock at your door one day and say, it's time. Suit up. It's time to go into outer space. It's exciting, but also unsettling. You think, why now? And your idea of yourself never really catches up. You put on the space suit and you learn to eat dehydrated food and poop while floating upside down or whatever. You adjust, but you never really feel like you're supposed to be up there, orbiting the earth. Thank you very much.
然后，就在你丢弃了最后一点点关于成为宇航员的幻想时，某天有人敲你的门说，该出发了。穿上制服。是时候去外太空了。这既令人兴奋，也令人不安。你会想，为什么是现在？而你对自己的看法永远赶不上现实。你穿上宇航服，学习吃脱水食品，在倒挂漂浮时排泄，等等。你适应了，但你从来没觉得你真的应该在那里，环绕地球飞行。非常感谢。
John Hodgman recorded at Royce Hall in Los Angeles. He's the author of the book, The Areas of My Expertise.
约翰·霍奇曼于洛杉矶罗伊斯大厅录制。他是《我的专业领域》一书的作者。
[MUSIC - "FAME AND FORTUNE" BY  MISSION OF BURMA]
[音乐 - 《名利》BY MISSION OF BURMA]
Act Two, Show Me the Annuity. Alex Blumberg has this story of a guy who ends up in what turns out to be the perfect job for him.
第二幕，“让我看看年金”。亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）带来了这个故事，讲述了一个人如何进入了一份对他来说恰到好处的工作。
Ed was working in a bar in Portland, Oregon, where he'd just moved with a bunch of friends from college, when he ran into trouble.
埃德（Ed）当时在俄勒冈州波特兰市的一家酒吧工作，他刚和一群大学朋友搬到那里，就遇到了麻烦。
Oregon at the time had pioneered an innovative new method of playing the state lottery. They'd come out with these video poker terminals that you played five card stud on for money, just like if you're playing online or at a casino. The difference was that all the money you won or lost came in or out of the Oregon state lottery fund.
当时的俄勒冈州首创了一种创新的彩票玩法。他们推出了这些视频扑克终端，你像在线上或赌场玩一样，用真钱玩五张牌梭哈。不同的是，你赢走或输掉的所有钱，都来自俄勒冈州彩票基金。
They were incredibly popular. Almost every bar in Portland had a few of these video poker machines. And Ed found them very hard to resist.
这些机器非常受欢迎。波特兰几乎每家酒吧都有几台这种视频扑克机。埃德发现它们非常难以抗拒。
If I had to be some place, let's say, at 7 o'clock, and I had an hour to kill, then I'd play for an hour. If I had $50 in my pocket, odds are I'd play those $50. And so, for me, I was so embarrassed of the fact that I was doing that, that that's really how I was spending so much of my free time, that I would tend to seek out bars in parts of the city that I knew my friends would be least prone to be in. And those bars that I often went to were strip clubs. And the fact that there were naked girls dancing around was bonus. It was a nice treat, but it really wasn't why I was there. I went to the strip clubs because I figured that odds are no one else would be at a strip club at 3 o'clock in the afternoon on a Tuesday.
如果我必须在某处，比如说7点钟，而我有一个小时的空闲时间，那我就会玩一个小时。如果我口袋里有50美元，很有可能我就会把那50美元投进去。所以，对我来说，我对自己这样做感到非常尴尬，因为那确实是我花掉大部分闲暇时间的方式，所以我倾向于寻找那些我知道朋友们最不会去的酒吧。而我经常去的那些酒吧是脱衣舞俱乐部。那里有脱光衣服跳舞的女孩算是一种加成。这是一个不错的招待，但那确实不是我去那里的原因。我去脱衣舞俱乐部是因为我觉得，周二下午3点钟，不太可能会有别人在脱衣舞俱乐部。
So you went to the strip clubs to play the lottery?
所以你去脱衣舞俱乐部是为了玩彩票？
Yeah.
是的。
It's like saying I read Playboy for the articles.
这就像说“我看《花花公子》是为了看里面的文章”。
I know, but meaning it.
我知道，但我是认真的。
And is it safe to say that one of the main reasons that you left Portland was because you were playing the lottery too much?
可以说你离开波特兰的主要原因之一就是因为你太沉迷于玩彩票了吗？
Absolutely. It was just better for all parties involved if I cut my losses and packed my truck and drove home, which is specifically what I did.
绝对是。如果我及时止损，打包好我的卡车开车回家，对所有相关方来说都会更好，这也就是我所做的。
Deep in debt and feeling pretty bad, Ed spent the next 14 months living in his parents' basement, stuck in a mid-20s career malaise. Until one night, he got a call from a friend saying that she'd met this guy. He owned a company and that the company was hiring.
埃德债台高筑，感觉很糟糕，接下来的14个月里，他一直住在父母的地下室里，陷入了20多岁职业生涯的低迷期。直到有一天晚上，他接到一个朋友的电话，说她遇到了一个人。他拥有一家公司，而且公司正在招聘。
Ed came in for an interview, and lo and behold, he got the job, a job that, before the interview, he hadn't even known existed, but for which he was strangely well prepared.
埃德去面试了，没想到他真的得到了这份工作，这份工作在他面试前甚至都不知道存在，但他却出人意料地做好了充分的准备。
The company buys and sells long-term payment streams from lottery winners.
这家公司买卖彩票中奖者的长期付款流。
The firm where Ed was hired was one of the first entrants into a fledgling industry, which called itself the lump sum industry. And to understand how it works, you have to understand a little about the lottery.
埃德受雇的这家公司是这个新兴行业的首批进入者之一，这个行业自称为“一次性付清行业”。要了解它是如何运作的，你必须对彩票有一定的了解。
Most lottery winners, especially in the '90s, when Ed started his job, didn't get all their money up front, but got paid in installments, annuities.
大多数彩票中奖者，尤其是在埃德开始工作的90年代，并不是一次性拿到所有奖金，而是按期领取年金。
So for example, if you won $1 million, that was actually only $50,000 a year for the next 20 years. 50,000 times 20 is a million. And with taxes, it's not even $50,000. It's more like $35,000.
例如，如果你中了100万美元，实际上那只是未来20年里每年5万美元。5万乘以20是100万。扣除税款后，甚至不到5万美元。更像是3.5万美元左右。
One of the big problems that comes as a result of that is that the way these winners are marketed to and the way, when they win, they say, $1 winner, millionaire, millionaire in all these different capacities. And on their billboards and in their radio advertising and TV advertising. And even though they know that they just got a check for $35,000, they go out and they start acting like they think a millionaire should act. And so, even though they've only got $35,000 in the bank, they go out and they buy a Porsche or they buy an Escalade, or they buy a new house, or two new houses, or six cars, or whatever it might be. And almost instantly, they get themselves in real hot water financially because they're living how they think they should, or think they can.
由此导致的一个大问题是，他们推销中奖者的方式，以及当他们中奖时，人们到处说“1美元中奖者，百万富翁，在各种层面上都是百万富翁”。在他们的广告牌、广播广告和电视广告中。即使他们知道自己刚拿到一张3.5万美元的支票，他们还是开始表现得像他们认为百万富翁应该表现的那样。所以，尽管他们的银行账户里只有3.5万美元，他们还是会去买保时捷，或者买凯迪拉克，或者买新房子，或者两栋新房子，或者六辆车，无论那是什么。几乎瞬间，他们就在经济上陷入了真正的困境，因为他们按照他们认为应该或认为自己能够的方式生活。
If you think you're a millionaire, and in reality what you're getting is an extra $35,000 a year, not only are you not a millionaire, you've barely cracked the next income level, basically. You know, you're barely in a different tax bracket.
如果你认为自己是百万富翁，而实际上你每年额外得到的是3.5万美元，那你不仅不是百万富翁，你甚至只是勉强跨入了下一个收入阶层，基本上。你知道，你几乎没进入不同的税级。
You're absolutely right. And believe me, broke lottery winners or financially troubled lottery winners are the rule. They are hardly the exception.
你说得完全正确。相信我，破产的彩票中奖者或财务陷入困境的彩票中奖者才是普遍现象。他们几乎不是例外。
Ed's job was to find these broke lottery winners and offer them cash up front, a lump sum, in exchange for the yearly checks they'd be getting from the lottery. Of course, the lump sum would be less than the total value of the long-term payments. So if you won $1 million, your lump sum would be about half that.
埃德的工作是找到这些破产的彩票中奖者，并为他们提供预付现金，即一次性总额，以换取他们原本从彩票中心领取的年度支票。当然，这个一次性总额会低于长期支付的总价值。所以如果你中了100万美元，你的一次性总额大约是那个数额的一半。
The industry advertises. They advertise on television, Judge Judy or all the daytime People's Court kind of things.
这个行业会做广告。他们在电视上做广告，在《朱迪法官》或所有日间《人民法庭》之类的节目中。
And then, generally, somebody will see an ad and then they'll call in to the firm.
通常，有人看到广告后会给公司打电话。
Yeah, and back when I first started there, we got so many call-ins that you could literally cherry pick. I mean, it was as competitive as the industry became. Back then, it was like the Wild Wild West. And not to mention, of course, there was a tremendous amount of cold calling out to them.
是的，当我刚开始在那里工作时，我们接到的电话非常多，以至于你简直可以挑肥拣瘦。我的意思是，这个行业变得多么竞争激烈。那时，就像狂野西部一样。更不用说，当然，还有大量的推销电话打给他们。
Jus pretend that I'm a lottery winner. You got me on the phone. What would you say as a cold caller? What do you say to me?
假设我是个彩票中奖者。你给我打了电话。作为一名推销员，你会说什么？你会对我说什么？
Well, you know, anything you can do not to get hung up on is a good place to start. Any question that you could ask that was going to give you a nugget to be able to work off of. You're trying to figure out, are they in any type of financial hardship, whether it's a good thing or a bad thing? I mean, a financial hardship might be that their daughter's getting married in the fall and they want to throw her a big lottery-winner wedding. And it could be something as sad as the fact that they're going bankrupt or they opened a restaurant and-- like, so many lottery winners open a restaurant, and they don't know the first thing about opening restaurants. And I mean, there's so many failed bars and restaurants that lottery winners sank money into. But anything that you could do to try to find out what they need money for, even if it hadn't occurred to them.
嗯，你知道，任何能让你不被挂断电话的事情都是一个好的开始。任何你能问出的问题，只要能给你提供一个可以利用的点。你试图弄清楚，他们是否处于任何类型的经济困难中，无论是好事还是坏事？我的意思是，经济困难可能是他们的女儿秋天要结婚，他们想给她举办一场盛大的彩票中奖者的婚礼。也可能是像他们濒临破产这样悲伤的事情，或者他们开了一家餐厅，就像很多彩票中奖者都开餐厅，他们对开餐厅一窍不通。我的意思是，有太多的失败酒吧和餐厅是彩票中奖者投入钱进去的。但任何你能做的事情，哪怕是试图找出他们需要钱的原因，即使之前没考虑到。
Ed quickly worked his way up, eventually becoming the best salesmen in the company, with a corner office and a multiple six-figure income.
埃德很快晋升，最终成为公司里最好的推销员，拥有转角的办公室和六位数的收入。
One thing to keep in mind. Ed was a middleman. He wasn't buying the lottery payments for himself, but on behalf of investors who put up a lump sum of cash now for a guaranteed income stream over the next 20 years. So if an investor was willing to pay, say, $500,000, and Ed got the lottery winner to agree to $480,000, then the firm made $20,000, A big portion of which went to Ed.
有一件事要记住。埃德是一个中间人。他不是为了自己购买彩票付款，而是代表那些现在投入一次性现金以换取未来20年保证收入流的投资者。所以，如果投资者愿意支付，比如说，50万美元，而埃德让彩票中奖者同意48万美元，那么公司就赚了2万美元，其中很大一部分归埃德所有。
The smaller the amount Ed got the lottery winner to agree to, the more money Ed made. And so the last thing Ed wanted to do was get into a deep discussion about the ins and outs of every deal, which, surprisingly, most lottery winners didn't want to do either.
埃德让彩票中奖者同意的金额越小，埃德赚的钱就越多。所以埃德最不想做的事情就是深入讨论每一笔交易的细节，出人意料的是，大多数彩票中奖者也不想讨论。
What Ed found was that, if lottery winners felt like they could relate to him, could trust him, then they'd be much more willing to do the deal, no matter what the terms. And Ed found it wasn't hard to get them comfortable because they actually had a lot in common.
埃德发现，如果彩票中奖者觉得他们能和他产生共鸣，能信任他，那么无论条款如何，他们都会更愿意进行交易。而且埃德发现让他们感到舒服并不难，因为他们确实有很多共同点。
It was just a natural fit for me. One of the biggest things that helped me was my intimate understanding of the mind of a gambler.
这对我来说是一个自然而然的契合点。对我帮助最大的一点是我对赌徒心态的深刻理解。
A fellow I did a deal with in Florida, we went to a notary to get certain pages of the contracts, all the contracts needed to be signed. Some of the signature pages needed to be notarized. And this notary happened to also sell lottery tickets. And when we went and got these pages notarized, he whipped out a wad of bills out of his pocket and bought 1,000 scratch tickets while the notary slash lottery ticket salesperson was notarizing the signature pages on his contract to sell me his annuity from the lottery win. He was sitting there. He didn't even look at the contracts. He's just scratching away. He couldn't even wait to get away from the booth. I'll never forget the way the notary looked at me sort of in awe. And yeah, it was a little daunting, a little bizarre seeing it. But I knew just who this cat was. I'd been that guy. And I would like to think that maybe I was a little bit better than scratch tickets in the airport, but I don't know that scratch tickets in the airport are that much classier than video poker machines in the strip clubs of Oregon.
我在佛罗里达做的一笔交易，我们去找了一位公证人，签署合同的所有页面，所有合同都需要签署。有些签名页需要公证。这位公证人刚好也卖彩票。当我们去公证这些页面时，他从口袋里掏出一叠钞票，买了1000张刮刮乐，而那位公证员兼彩票销售员正在公证他出售彩票年金合同的签名页。他就坐在那里。他甚至没看合同。他只是在那刮个不停。他甚至等不及离开柜台。我永远忘不了那位公证员看着我时那种敬畏的神情。是的，这有点令人畏惧，有点离奇。但我知道这人是谁。我曾经就是那个人。我愿意认为或许我比机场里买刮刮乐的人好一点，但我不知道机场里的刮刮乐是否比俄勒冈州脱衣舞俱乐部的视频扑克机高档多少。
Do you think that that was part of what made you good, that you could see yourself making the exact same choices that they had made?
你认为这是你擅长这项工作的部分原因吗，你能看到自己做出和他们完全一样的选择？
I think it was my secret weapon. Forget about what I pretended to be in the office, but I knew who I was when I looked in the mirror. And I knew I was a lottery winner. I just never bought a ticket.
我认为这是我的秘密武器。别管我在办公室里装成什么样，但我照镜子时知道自己是谁。我知道我就是一个彩票中奖者。我只是从来没买过彩票。
We've all heard stories about how winning the lottery can be a mixed blessing, with the unwanted attention and the cousins of friends of coworkers looking for handouts. But when Ed discusses lottery winners, it can sound like he's talking about someone getting cancer. Because in his experience, it's not even a mixed blessing. It's a catastrophe.
我们都听说过关于中奖可能会带来喜忧参半的结果的故事，伴随着不想要的关注，以及同事朋友的远房亲戚来讨要钱财。但当埃德讨论彩票中奖者时，听起来就像他在谈论某人得了癌症一样。因为在他的经验中，这甚至不是喜忧参半的祝福。这是一场灾难。
Of the winners he's met, he figures 80% of them wished they'd never won. More money often just intensifies your own worst tendencies and allows you to get in much worse trouble, be it through gambling, philandering, drinking, or just plain boneheadedness than you ever could have at $15 an hour. And, he says, it makes you paranoid.
在他见过的人中，他觉得80%的人希望他们从来没有中过奖。更多的钱往往只会加剧你自身最坏的倾向，并让你陷入比你每小时赚15美元时更糟糕的麻烦中，无论是通过赌博、拈花惹草、酗酒还是仅仅因为愚蠢。而且，他说，这会让你变得偏执。
He did a deal with one woman. He showed up at her house for their appointment.
他和一位女士做了一笔交易。他去她家参加预约。
I get into her front yard and the second I opened-- there's a gate to her front yard. And she opened her front door, purposely letting out maybe seven or eight huge dogs that cornered me. I'm a dog person. I grew up with dogs. I love dogs, but not these dogs. These dogs literally cornered me in the corner of her yard. And I kept this sort of smile on my face thinking that, OK, this is a little awkward, but I don't want to ruin the deal. She's obviously coming out to deal with the dogs. She's going to come and she's going to pull the dogs off me. But she just sort of cracked her head outside. And I'm sitting there. I have my hands up and I have my briefcase over my shoulder. And she says to me, she says, do you have an offer?
我进到她的前院，我一打开——她前院有个门。她打开前门，故意放出了大概七八只巨大的狗，把我也困住了。我是个爱狗的人。我从小就有狗。我爱狗，但不爱这些狗。这些狗真的把我围在了她院子的角落里。我脸上带着那种微笑，心想，好吧，这有点尴尬，但我不想破坏交易。她显然是出来处理狗的。她会出来，把狗从我身上引开。但她只是把头探出来看了看。我坐在那。我举着双手，把公文包扛在肩上。她对我说，她说，“你有报价吗？”
I thought she was kidding. At first I did. I laughed. I remember nervously laughing. But it kind of quickly occurred to me that maybe these dogs out in the yard wasn't fully a mistake on her part. If nothing else, it surely got my attention. And I will tell you, it worked. It did. I mean those dogs made her at least $10,000.
我以为她在开玩笑。起初我是这么想的。我笑了。我记得我神经质地笑了。但很快我意识到，或许她在院子里放这些狗并不是完全无意的。如果说有什么作用的话，那就是它确实引起了我的注意。我会告诉你，它奏效了。确实。我的意思是那些狗至少为她赚了1万美元。
But the dogs were just the tip of the paranoia iceberg. The woman agreed to Ed's figure from her doorway, grabbed her keys, and said, let's go. They headed to the notary, she in her car, Ed in his rental. But when Ed pulled into the parking space at the notary, the woman zoomed away. Eventually, she called Ed from a pay phone and told him that she was reconsidering. Ed tried to talk her down over the phone, but this was a little difficult.
但这些狗只是她偏执冰山的一角。这位女士在门口同意了埃德提出的数字，抓起钥匙，说，“我们走吧。”他们开车前往公证处，她开自己的车，埃德开租来的车。但当埃德把车开进公证处的停车位时，那位女士飞快地开走了。最终，她从公用电话给埃德打电话，告诉他她在重新考虑。埃德试图在电话里说服她，但这有点困难。
I guess she had watched too many cop shows or too many movies, because even though I'd been at her house, and I'd spoken to her on the phone, and I knew what her phone number was, and I knew where to find if I wanted her, she was afraid, somehow, that on my cellphone that I would be able to figure out where she was if she stayed on the phone with me for more than 30 seconds at a time. Because in the movies-- and who knows if it's true-- but classically, that's how long it takes to tap a phone or to do a search, or whatever it, where you find out their location.
我猜她看太多警察剧或电影了，因为尽管我曾去过她家，我也和她通过电话，我知道她的电话号码，如果我想找她也知道去哪里找，但她仍然担心，不知怎么的，我在手机上能追踪到她的位置，如果她和我通话超过30秒的话。因为在电影里——谁知道是不是真的——但通常情况下，这就是窃听电话或进行搜索所需的时间，无论那是什么，他们能找到你的位置。
So for the next two days, I'm down in this town in Virginia. And we developed a whole new relationship on the phone, sort of starting from scratch and going through the entire sales process. But now, we'd be talking and you could literally set your watch to it. And we would talk for-- you know, 30 seconds isn't a hell of a long time when you're try to get a deal done. And every 30 seconds, boom, she'd hang up again. And she'd call right back. Or she'd wait a minute or two, or whatever it was. But the one thing I tried to do was not to talk too fast. I didn't want to seem like I was fazed by the fact that I only had 30 seconds. And so I'd be very casual. And I'd ask her how she's doing and if she's thought anymore about it.
所以接下来的两天，我就呆在弗吉尼亚州的这个小镇里。我们在电话里建立了一种全新的关系，从零开始，走完了整个销售流程。但现在，我们交谈时，你简直可以按表计时。我们交谈——你知道，当你试图完成一笔交易时，30秒可不是一段长得离谱的时间。每隔30秒，砰，她就会再次挂断。然后她会立刻打回来。或者她会等一两分钟，无论是什么情况。但我试图做的一件事是不说得太快。我不想看起来好像被我只有30秒的事实吓坏了。所以我表现得很随意。我会问她过得怎么样，是否又想过这件事。
And then sometimes in the middle of a sentence she'd just hang up. And sometimes even when she was feeling, I guess, a little bit more relaxed, she'd forget about the 30 seconds and I'd even remind her. And then she'd hang up. And I'd sit there and wait and then she'd call me back on my phone. And this went on for two days. That's the way, in the end, that we were able to get our deal done, is if she was able to regain a sense of control that she somehow felt she had lost pulling into the notary.
有时话说到一半，她就会挂断。有时即使当她感觉稍微放松一些时，她也会忘记30秒的事，我甚至会提醒她。然后她就会挂断。我就坐在那里等着，然后她又打回我的手机。这种情况持续了两天。到最后，我们能够完成交易的方式就是，如果她能重新获得一种她进入公证处停车位时感觉失去的控制感。
Do you think that she was that paranoid before, or do you think this was all because she was a lottery winner?
你认为她之前就是那么偏执，还是你认为这完全是因为她是彩票中奖者？
I think that it was as a direct result of the lottery. I think that it was an absolute cause effect.
我认为这是彩票的直接结果。我认为这是一种绝对的因果关系。
Ed left his job after seven years, partly for reasons anyone leaves a high stakes, high pressure sales job: the stress, the competition, the constant travel. But there was another part, too. Ed believed in the lump sum option. Still does. It makes more sense to take the money up front and invest it, than it does to let the state hold onto it interest free for 20 years. But it doesn't necessarily make sense to buy the lump sum from Ed, the middle man, because he's taking a cut for himself. And this was the inescapable truth to Ed's job, a truth that, because he identified so much with lottery winners, he found it especially hard to ignore.
埃德在工作了七年后辞职了，部分原因是任何人离开一份高风险、高压力的销售工作的原因：压力、竞争、不断的差旅。但还有另一个原因。埃德相信一次性总额选项。现在依然相信。比起让州政府免费占用20年的利息，预先拿到钱并投资更有意义。但从中间人埃德那里购买一次性总额并不一定有意义，因为他自己要抽取佣金。这是埃德工作的一个不可避免的事实，一个因为他与彩票中奖者产生了如此多共鸣，以至于他觉得特别难以忽视的事实。
The more the lottery winners liked him, the less likely they were to notice how big a cut he took. And the more desperate they were for cash, the more lucrative Ed's deal was likely to be.
彩票中奖者越喜欢他，就越不可能注意到他抽走了多少佣金。他们越是急需现金，埃德的交易就越可能利润丰厚。
There was a fella who needed to do a deal and needed to do a deal right away. And in the lump sum game, that's real good. But the reason that it gave me sort of the heebie-jeebies was why he needed to do the deal.
有个家伙需要完成一笔交易，而且需要马上完成。在一次性总额的博弈中，这非常好。但让我觉得毛骨悚然的原因是他为什么要完成这笔交易。
This fella, who's a terrific guy, but he needed to sell his entire prize in five minutes, so he could put a half million dollars into a very famous defense attorney's bank account so that he, the attorney, would defend his son, the lottery winner's son, in a murder trial. And the son, as we speak, was found guilty. He was found guilty in his appeal. A young kid, 18, 19 years old, killed a woman. And this winner, he had to get in bed with the lump sum industry and he had to sell his payment under very rushed circumstances, which, of course, is to his detriment. And he had to do all that because he was trying to save his son from going to prison for the rest of his life.
这个家伙，人非常好，但他需要在五分钟内卖掉他全部的奖金，这样他才能把50万美元存入一位非常有名的辩护律师的银行账户，以便律师为他的儿子，也就是彩票中奖者的儿子，在谋杀案审判中辩护。而就在我们交谈时，那个儿子被判有罪。他在上诉中被判有罪。一个18、19岁的孩子，杀了一个女人。这位中奖者，他不得不与一次性总额行业同流合污，他不得不在非常匆忙的情况下出售他的付款，这当然对他是不利的。他必须做所有这些，因为他试图拯救他的儿子不至于在监狱里度过余生。
And in the end, he got a good deal, but we made a few dollars, too. And I think that that sort of ambiguity was always present in a lottery deal. It was always there. It was always sort of riding shotgun in the car with me, that, yeah, I might be solving his problem, but I'm sure as hell not hurting mine.
最后，他达成了一笔好交易，但我们也赚了一些钱。我认为那种模糊性一直存在于彩票交易中。它一直都在。它一直像是和我坐在车里的副驾驶一样，是的，我可能正在解决他的问题，但我绝不会伤害我的利益。
And it's also sort of like in a way you're profiting from his problem.
这在某种程度上也就像是在从他的问题中获利。
Not in a way, absolutely. And there's nothing wrong with that, but isn't there? That's OK. I mean, people profit all the time from other people's problems, but it never made me feel great. You know what I mean? Like, you were looking for people that were in bad shape because people who are in bad shape put me in good shape.
不是在某种程度上，是绝对。这没什么错，但真的吗？这没关系。我的意思是，人们一直从别人的问题中获利，但这从来没让我感觉很好。你知道我的意思吗？就像，你一直在找那些处境糟糕的人，因为处境糟糕的人让我处境良好。
In the year since Ed first got into the business, the lump sum industry has gone through huge changes. New companies entered the field, increasing competition. The states themselves got into the action. A decade ago, almost none of them offered a lump sum option to their lottery winners. Today, almost all of them do.
在埃德进入这个行业后的几年里，一次性总额行业发生了巨大的变化。新公司进入该领域，竞争加剧。州政府自己也加入了行动。十年前，几乎没有哪个州为他们的彩票中奖者提供一次性总额选项。今天，几乎所有州都提供。
And they offer pretty much the exact same terms Ed was offering, roughly $0.5 million up front on a $1 million win, but minus, of course, Ed's commission. The state has effectively cut out the middlemen like Ed. The overwhelming majority of winners take their deal.
而且他们提供的条款和埃德之前提供的大致相同，中100万，预付大约50万，当然减去了埃德的佣金。州政府实际上排除了像埃德这样的中间人。绝大多数中奖者接受了州政府的方案。
Alex Blumberg is one of the producers of our program. Ed Ugel has written a book about his time in the lottery industry. It comes out in September and is called, Money for Nothing.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格是我们节目的制作人之一。埃德·尤格尔（Ed Ugel）写了一本关于他在彩票行业经历的书。它将于九月出版，书名叫《不劳而获》（Money for Nothing）。
Coming up, out on the frontier, treading the new world. The only thing lacking is a salt shaker. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，在边境线上，踏入新世界。唯一缺少的东西就是个盐瓶。那是一分钟后的事情，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
[MUSIC - "WORK SONG" BY VINCE GUERALDI]
[音乐 - 《工作之歌》BY VINCE GUERALDI]
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Nice Work If You Can Get It, stories about people who land dream jobs, and how even dream jobs have parts that aren't really necessary so dreamy.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目，“如果你能得到，这是不错的工作”，关于那些找到梦幻工作的人，以及即使是梦幻工作也有一些并不那么梦幻的部分的故事。
We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, The Homesick Explorer.
我们的节目进入了第三幕。第三幕，“思乡的探险家”。
When we think of the Fremont expeditions to map the American West, as we so often do, we think of epic men, the kind of men who don't call their jobs jobs. They call their jobs destinies. Well, Sarah Vowell has some thoughts about one of the lesser-known guys on that trip, and the job he did.
当我们想到弗里蒙特（Fremont）绘制美国西部地图的探险时，我们常会想到史诗般的人物，那种不把工作称为工作的人。他们称工作为命运。好吧，莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）对那次旅行中鲜为人知的一个人以及他的工作有一些想法。
John Charles Fremont was the spirited flashing light of a man from whom Las Vegas' flashy, lit-up Fremont Street would one day get its name.
约翰·查尔斯·弗里蒙特是一个充满活力、闪闪发光的男人，拉斯维加斯那条闪亮、灯火通明的弗里蒙特街有一天将以他的名字命名。
In 1842, the United States government sent him to lead one of the most important expeditions of the 19th century, a mission to make maps and issue reports on what would come to be called the Oregon Trail. He hired the famous fur trapper and mountaineer, Kit Carson, to be the expedition scout. To make maps and drawings along the way, Fremont employed a German immigrant named Charles Preuss.
1842年，美国政府派他领导19世纪最重要的探险之一，一项为后来被称为俄勒冈小道的地方制作地图并发布报告的任务。他雇佣了著名的毛皮猎人和登山家基特·卡森（Kit Carson）担任探险向导。为了沿途制作地图和绘图，弗里蒙特聘请了一位名叫查尔斯·普鲁斯（Charles Preuss）的德国移民。
Fremont's lively report to Congress of his findings, illustrated with Preuss's drawings and maps, became a bestseller. And Preuss's map of the Oregon trail Congress published in 1846 was soon crammed into the glove box of every Conestoga rolling West.
弗里蒙特给国会的生动调查报告，配有普鲁斯的图画和地图，成为了畅销书。普鲁斯绘制的俄勒冈小道地图在1846年由国会出版，很快就被塞进了每一辆西进的康尼斯托加篷车的储物箱里。
If you ever had to reach across a copy of the Book of Mormon blocking the Parmesan cheese at a pizza place outside of Provo, it's because Brigham Young was so intrigued with Fremont's description of the bucolic area surrounding Utah's Great Salt Lake, he promptly moved his Mormon brethren there.
如果你曾经在普罗沃外的一家披萨店里，越过一本挡住帕玛森干酪的《摩门经》，那是因为杨百翰对弗里蒙特关于犹他州大盐湖周边田园风光的描述非常感兴趣，并迅速将他的摩门教徒兄弟们迁往那里。
So Charles Preuss was one of the most important, influential, and talented cartographers of his generation. Problem was, this excellent mapmaker just so happened to loathe pretty much every minute of actual exploring. Preuss's diaries from his three trips out West with Fremont seethe with manly, gung-ho cowboy bravery like--
所以查尔斯·普鲁斯是他那一代最重要、最有影响力、最有天赋的地图绘制者之一。问题是，这位出色的制图师刚好厌恶实际探险的每一分钟。普鲁斯在与弗里蒙特的三次西部之行中的日记中，充斥着那种牛仔式的勇敢，比如——
I wish I were at the market with a shopping basket.
我真希望我能提着购物篮在市场里。
Or, mulling over the roasting mule meat that is to be his dinner.
或者，在思索要作为晚餐的烤骡肉时。
What a treat it would be with a bottle of wine. But stop, that thought is too beautiful.
要是有一瓶酒该多好。但别想了，那个念头太美好了。
Preuss's boss on the trip, John Charles Fremont, was manifest destiny's advance man. As a young surveyor, he'd cut his teeth mapping the Cherokee lands in the southeast in the 1830s, so the US government had an accurate account of the real estate it was about to steal.
普鲁斯的老板，约翰·查尔斯·弗里蒙特，是天命论的先驱。作为一名年轻的测量员，他在1830年代在东南部绘制切罗基族土地地图时开始崭露头角，以便美国政府能准确掌握它即将窃取的房地产的情况。
Later on, Fremont came home from his expeditions out West a hero and celebrity. His nickname, "The Pathfinder." He went on to become the first presidential candidate of the Republican party. And the signature image used for all his later self-promotion, including his presidential campaign, was one incident from his Western journeys. It became the iconic moment of his life, what crossing the Delaware was for Washington, what tripping over the ottoman was for Dick Van Dyke. Fremont climbed alone to what he thought was the highest peak in the Rockies, stood up straight and tall and jabbed an American flag into the mountain top, Old Glory whipping defiantly in the icy wind.
后来，弗里蒙特从西部探险归来，成为了一位英雄和名人。他的绰号是“开拓者”。他后来成为共和党的第一位总统候选人。他后来所有自我宣传（包括总统竞选）中使用的标志性图像，都是他西部之旅中的一个片段。这成为了他人生中最具标志性的时刻，就像华盛顿渡过特拉华河，就像迪克·范·戴克被脚垫绊倒一样。弗里蒙特独自爬上他认为落基山脉的最高峰，站得笔直，将一面美国国旗刺入山顶，旧荣耀旗帜在冰冷的风中倔强地飘扬。
Think about the kind of person you have to be to do that, to be so unapologetically grand.
想想你需要成为什么样的人才能做到那样，表现得如此毫不掩饰地宏大。
Preuss, meanwhile, was farther down the mountain, striking a less Neil Armstrongy pose.
与此同时，普鲁斯在山下更远的地方，表现出一种不太像尼尔·阿姆斯特朗的姿势。
I slipped, sat down on my pants, and slid downhill at a great speed. Although I made all efforts to hold back by trying to dig my fingers into the icy crust, I slid down about 200 feet until the bare rock stopped me again. When I arrived, I rolled over twice and got away with two light bruises, one on my right arm, and one on my arse. The pain made me sit still for a few minutes.
我滑倒了，屁股着地，以极快的速度向山下溜去。尽管我尽力尝试用手指抠进冰壳来阻止下滑，但我还是溜了大约200英尺，直到裸露的岩石才挡住了我。当我停下时，我翻滚了两次，只受了点轻伤，右臂上一处，屁股上一处。疼痛让我静静地坐了几分钟。
Fremont wrote of this climb that, standing where never a human foot had stood before, that he "felt the exaltation of first explorers."
弗里蒙特在日记中写道，站在从未有人类脚踏过的地方，他“感受到了第一批探险家的崇高感”。
Preuss put it this way.
普鲁斯是这样说的。
All my pants are torn.
我的裤子全破了。
Preuss's resentment of the bugs, the landscape, the Indians, and the monotony, pales compared to his many varied flipouts about food. His entry for June 12, 1842 cheers up with the slaughter of an ox. Preuss thinks that after the meat ages overnight--
普鲁斯对虫子、景观、印第安人和单调生活的怨恨，与他关于食物的各种烦恼相比简直是小巫见大巫。他1842年6月12日的日记随着一头牛的宰杀而变得开朗起来。普鲁斯认为在肉类存放一夜后——
Tomorrow, to be sure, it will taste excellent.
明天，肯定会尝起来很棒。
June 13.
6月13日。
It did not taste excellent.
尝起来一点也不棒。
Preuss has an entire subset of food complaints involving salt and the lack thereof. One of his happiest entries takes place in the Sierra Mountains on February 15, 1843, near what is now the California-Nevada border.
普鲁斯有一整套关于食物的抱怨，涉及盐以及缺乏盐的情况。他最快乐的日记条目之一发生在1843年2月15日的内华达山脉，靠近现在的加利福尼亚州与内华达州边界。
The great good news is that the men have bartered rock salt from the Indians. Just now, Taplin is bringing in a big lump.
天大的好消息是男人们从印第安人那里换到了岩盐。刚才，塔普林带回来一大块。
Preuss was so giddy about the salt that he doesn't mention what the expedition was doing while they were waiting around for the seasoning to show up: discovering Lake Tahoe.
普鲁斯对盐太兴奋了，以至于他根本没提探险队在等待调味品出现时在做什么：发现太浩湖。
It makes sense that Preuss, a man who was outstanding at measuring and drawing and using barometric data to construct a two-dimensional topographical representation of a mountain, might suck at climbing said mountain. Cartography was Preuss's calling. But in order for him to do the job he loved to do, he had to live a life he hated.
普鲁斯是一个擅长测量、绘画并利用气压数据构建山脉二维地形图的人，但在这座山上攀登时表现糟糕，这说得通。地图绘制是普鲁斯的使命。但为了做他热爱的工作，他不得不生活在一种他憎恨的生活中。
The thing I admire most about Charles Preuss is that Fremont, his boss, apparently had no idea just how miserable the cartographer was on the job. Preuss' diaries were meant for one reader, his wife, and they weren't published until 1958, after Preuss and all his colleagues had been dead for a century.
我最佩服查尔斯·普鲁斯的一点是，他的老板弗里蒙特似乎完全不知道这位制图师在工作时有多痛苦。普鲁斯的日记是写给一位读者的，他的妻子，直到1958年，在普鲁斯和他所有的同事都去世一个世纪后才出版。
In fact, Fremont commended Preuss for "his even temper and patient endurance of hardship," noting Preuss had a "cheerful philosophy of his own, which often brightened dark situations."
事实上，弗里蒙特称赞普鲁斯“性情温和，能忍受困苦”，并指出普鲁斯有一种“他自己乐观的哲学，这经常点亮黑暗的境况”。
I respect that. Preuss had a job to do and he bucked up and did it.
我尊重这一点。普鲁斯有工作要做，他振作起来并完成了它。
The other people on these expeditions, John Charles Fremont, and his legendary scout, Kit Carson, are the sort of grand, hardy, how-the-west-was-won figures who are easily made into colossal statues. But there's something comforting, even heroic, about a human scale footnote like Preuss, a man who made history even though all he ever wanted was to make maps.
探险队里的其他人，约翰·查尔斯·弗里蒙特和他传奇的向导基特·卡森，是那种容易被雕刻成宏大雕像的、强健的“西部是如何被征服的”式人物。但像普鲁斯这样的人类尺度注脚有一些安慰，甚至是英雄色彩，一个创造了历史，尽管他唯一想做的只是绘制地图的人。
Sarah Vowell. She's the author most recently of Assassination Vacation. Charles Preuss' diaries were read by actor Dermot Mulroney.
莎拉·沃威尔。她最近的一部书是《刺杀度假》（Assassination Vacation）。查尔斯·普鲁斯的日记由演员德蒙特·莫罗尼（Dermot Mulroney）朗读。
[MUSIC - "DESERT BLUES" BY JIMMIE RODGERS]
[音乐 - 《沙漠蓝调》BY JIMMIE RODGERS]
Act Four, Just One Thing Missing.
第四幕，“只缺了一样东西”。
Well, we end our show today with somebody who was blocked from getting their dream job, blocked by the government of the United States of America. Douglas McGray has the story. He's changed the name of the woman in this story to protect her identity.
嗯，我们今天以一个被拒绝获得梦幻工作的人的故事结束节目，被美利坚合众国政府拒绝。道格拉斯·麦格雷（Douglas McGray）带来了这个故事。他更改了故事中这个女人的名字以保护她的身份。
Martha doesn't like to talk about her future anymore. She'd wanted to go to med school, become an OB/GYN. And she's exactly the kind of kid everyone roots for.
玛莎（Martha）不再谈论她的未来了。她曾想上医学院，成为一名妇产科医生。她正是那种每个人都会支持的孩子。
She grew up in a poor, mostly immigrant neighborhood in east LA, where most people didn't graduate from high school, and nobody talked about college. But Martha got into UCLA. She couldn't believe it, UCLA.
她在洛杉矶东部一个贫困、移民为主的街区长大，那里大多数人没有高中毕业，没有人谈论大学。但玛莎考上了加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）。她简直不敢相信，加州大学洛杉矶分校。
She majored in chemistry, threw herself into six-hour lab sessions, ran a volunteer organization on campus. But the fact is, she can't become a doctor. She can't work at all in the United States, not legally, anyway. She's an undocumented immigrant. Her mother brought her to the US from Mexico when she was nine.
她主修化学，全心投入六小时的实验室课程，在校园里运营一个志愿者组织。但事实是，她不能成为医生。她根本不能在美国工作，至少合法途径是不行的。她是一名无证移民。她九岁时母亲把她从墨西哥带到了美国。
So now she's a waitress, earning minimum wage, working off the books. And it may be the best job she can hope to get. The worst part?
所以现在她是一名服务员，赚着最低工资，非法工作。而这可能是她能希望得到的最好工作。最糟糕的部分？
Well, first of all, I suck at it. My boss always gets these complaints for me. Oh, she takes too long to get my drinks. She forgot to put this on my order. She changed my order. I asked her well done and she brought medium. And I'm extremely clumsy. I really suck at it. I can't multitask. I'm horrible at that. I don't know what's wrong with me. I'm very clumsy by nature and you can't be a clumsy waitress. You know, that's like an oxymoron. And that's one thing.
嗯，首先，我真的很笨。老板总是因为我接到投诉。哦，她送饮料太慢了。她忘记把这个放进订单里了。她改了我的订单。我要求全熟，她送来的是中熟。而且我非常笨拙。我真的很烂。我不能一心多用。我在这方面太糟糕了。我不知道自己怎么了。我天生就很笨拙，你不能当个笨拙的服务员。你知道，这就像自相矛盾。这是一回事。
And the other thing is I am a very proud person. I don't like people treating me a certain way. So many people have come and told me, oh, here, here's $20 for the milk for your baby boy. People look at me and right off the bat assume that I have a bunch of children, I'm probably a single mother. And that bothers me. And I don't know. I think being a waitress bothers me because people don't see my potential.
另外一件事是我是一个非常自尊的人。我不喜欢别人那样对待我。很多人告诉我，哦，这里，这是20美元给你的小男孩买奶粉。人们看着我，立刻假设我有一堆孩子，我可能是一个单身母亲。这让我很困扰。我不知道。我觉得当服务员很困扰我，因为人们看不到我的潜力。
When Martha arrived at UCLA, she figured she'd be the only undocumented kid there. But she was wrong. She found others. A high school valedictorian and prom queen from Compton who went to UCLA when the Marines rejected her. Only legal residents can enlist.
当玛莎来到加州大学洛杉矶分校时，她以为自己是那里唯一的无证学生。但她错了。她找到了其他人。一个来自康普顿的高中毕业生代表和舞会皇后，她在海军陆战队拒绝她后进入了加州大学洛杉矶分校。只有合法居民才能入伍。
Another valedictorian, brought to the United States as an infant who spoke her first word in English. A shy girl who arrived as a toddler and took 11 AP classes in high school. They're a tiny, close community. They actually have a small student club. They go out and mentor undocumented high school kids and raise money for scholarships. And they understand each other in a way that no one else can, like what they go through to stay in school.
另一个是毕业生代表，婴儿时期被带到美国，第一个词说的是英语。一个害羞的女孩，幼儿时期抵达，在高中修了11门大学先修课程（AP）。他们是一个微小、紧密的社区。他们实际上有一个小型学生俱乐部。他们出去指导无证的高中生并筹集奖学金。他们以一种其他人无法理解的方式理解彼此，比如他们为了留在学校所经历的一切。
Most live really far from campus. Two and a half hours in Martha's case. And they have to be creative to survive.
大多数人住得离校园很远。玛莎的情况是两个半小时。他们必须有创造力才能生存。
Being on hobo mode is something that we students, undocumented students, specifically, that's what we call it. It's living on campus because we don't have a home near campus because we can't afford it. It's really expensive. So we'd stay here days at a time. Sometimes a week. Or sometimes, in my case, I did it weeks at a time. I would stay in the library and sleep in the library. I would store my food in, like, a lounge in a building. I would take showers in the locker room. And I would store all my clothing because I'd bring underwear. I'd bring a change of clothes for every single day and store it in the locker room. It's really difficult to do that. And also, it's kind of stigmatizing because you kind of get ashamed if people find out you're in hobo mode.
处于“流浪模式”是我们学生，特别是无证学生，我们这么称呼它。这住在校园里，因为我们没有靠近校园的家，因为我们负担不起。太贵了。所以我们有时候一住就是几天。有时候一周。有时候，我的情况，我住过几周。我会在图书馆呆着，在图书馆睡觉。我会把食物存在一栋楼的休息室里。我会去更衣室洗澡。我会存下所有的衣服，因为我会带内衣。我会带每一天的换洗衣服，存放在更衣室。这样做真的很困难。而且，这也带有一种污名，因为如果别人发现你在“流浪模式”，你会感到羞耻。
20 years ago, California allowed undocumented kids to go to state universities with financial aid and everything. Five years later, the courts reversed that. Kids like Martha would have to pay huge out-of-state fees. Four years after that, a ballot initiative barred undocumented kids from college altogether. Then the courts got involved again.
20年前，加利福尼亚州允许无证学生通过助学金等方式进入州立大学。五年后，法院推翻了这一点。像玛莎这样的孩子必须支付巨额的州外费用。四年后，一项投票提案彻底禁止了无证学生进入大学。然后法院再次介入。
Today, the laws for someone like Martha are different in every state. 10 states, including California and Texas, allow undocumented kids to go to state schools and pay in-state tuition, but no financial aid, no Pell Grant, no work study job, not even a student loan.
今天，像玛莎这样的人在每个州的法律都不同。包括加州和得克萨斯州在内的10个州，允许无证学生进入州立学校并支付州内学费，但没有助学金，没有佩尔奖学金，没有勤工俭学工作，甚至没有学生贷款。
To apply for a green card, which would solve all their problems, Martha would have to quit school, move to Mexico, wait in a line that can stretch 10 or 15 years, and most likely get rejected.
为了申请绿卡，那将解决他们所有的问题，玛莎必须退学，搬到墨西哥，排一个长达10到15年的队，并且最有可能被拒绝。
Last year, Martha found a perfect job to support herself, on campus even. But she couldn't accept it. A UCLA professor needed a research assistant, someone to help her interview Spanish-speaking families in East LA. Martha knew the neighborhood, spoke Spanish fluently. The professor called Martha to say she got the job.
去年，玛莎找到了一份养活自己的完美工作，甚至在校园里。但她不能接受。一位加州大学洛杉矶分校的教授需要一名研究助理，一个能帮助她采访洛杉矶东部说西班牙语家庭的人。玛莎了解那个社区，西班牙语说得很流利。教授打电话给玛莎说她得到了那份工作。
And I got the phone call. I was so excited. I was like, oh my God. This is a really good job. But it didn't click to me that I was going to be on the payroll. I thought, oh, well, maybe she can just pay me cash or whatever. I was very naive. And I was really bummed out. But I try not to think about it too much.
我接到了那个电话。我太兴奋了。我说，哦，天哪。这是一份非常好的工作。但我没意识到我会进入工资单。我想，哦，好吧，也许她可以付给我现金什么的。我太天真了。我真的很沮丧。但我尽量不多想它。
What kept you motivated through all of this?
是什么让你在这一切中保持动力？
Med school. I want to go to med school. I wanted to be-- I still want to. I mean, there's still a possibility it could happen, it's just not now.
医学院。我想上医学院。我想成为——我依然想。我的意思是，还有可能发生，只是不是现在。
Why do you want to be a doctor?
为什么你想成为医生？
I want to be a doctor because I've always seen myself as a public servant. But I also see myself as a scientist. And to me, that's the only thing that I see myself doing. Because it gains you respect from people. And well, right now, I try not to think about it because it depresses me that I can't do it right now.
我想成为医生是因为我一直把自己视为一名公仆。但我同时也把自己视为一名科学家。对我来说，那是我唯一能看到自己做的事情。因为它能为你赢得人们的尊重。而且，现在，我尽量不去想它，因为它让我感到沮丧，我无法做到这一点。
Listening to you, I get the sense that you think that respect is something you have to fight for.
听你说话，我感觉到你认为尊重是你必须争取的东西。
Yes. Unfortunately, not everybody gets respect just by being a human being. I'm not the kind of person that seeks power. I don't like that. I don't want to rule people. You know, that's not what I want. I'm not ambitious in that sense. I just would like to be someone whose opinion people respect. Someone like, say, oh, there's this really important issue that we need to solve and we need your help. Or someone that people will say, oh, look, there she is. Let's go talk to her because we really like her work. We really like what she does. That kind of thing.
是的。不幸的是，并不是每个人仅仅作为一个人就能得到尊重。我不是那种追求权力的人。我不喜欢那样。我不想统治人们。你知道，那不是我想要的。我没有那种意义上的野心。我只是想成为一个别人尊重其意见的人。就像，哦，有一个非常重要的问题需要解决，我们需要你的帮助。或者人们会说，哦，看，她在那儿。我们去和她聊聊吧，因为我们真的很喜欢她的工作。我们真的很喜欢她所做的事情。那种事情。
When Martha and I talked, she kept calling herself a quitter. She said the word like it was the worst word she knew. She said it over and over. I told her she was being ridiculous. I've known Martha for almost two years and I've never seen someone put so much pressure on herself.
当玛莎和我交谈时，她一直称自己为失败者。她一遍遍说那个词，好像那是她知道的最糟糕的词。我告诉她她太荒谬了。我认识玛莎快两年了，我从未见过有人给自己施加这么大的压力。
When her grades were mediocre, she wouldn't blame her home life, or her commute, or the pair of double waitressing shifts she worked most weekends. She would just say she hadn't tried hard enough.
当她的成绩一般时，她不会责怪家庭生活、通勤，或者她大多数周末都在做的双倍服务员轮班。她只会说她没有足够努力。
One quarter, desperate to find more time to study, she actually started driving to school even though it scared her to drive without a license. As an undocumented immigrant, she's not allowed to get one.
有一个学期，因为迫切想找到更多时间学习，她真的开始开车上学，尽管她害怕在没有驾照的情况下开车。作为一名无证移民，她是不被允许获得驾照的。
I kept asking her, what do you mean, quitter? Finally, she explained.
我一直问她，你是什么意思，失败者？最终，她解释了。
Fall quarter, I just gave up on myself. I dropped all my classes and I withdrew from the quarter, because I felt so tired. I felt like, I don't want to do this anymore.
秋季学期，我只是放弃了自己。我退掉了所有的课，退出了那个学期，因为我感到太累了。我觉得，我不想再这样做了。
That was the quarter that you were going to graduate at the end of that quarter?
那个学期是你打算在学期末毕业的吗？
Right at that quarter. Can you believe that? It was the last quarter. I could have just worked harder, but I didn't. I was just so overwhelmed. My future is so uncertain and so unbelievably sad that I think to myself, well, why should I try, like, harder? I just gave up on that. [CRYING] Sorry. I shouldn't give up because a lot of people don't and the fact that I do really hurts me.
就在那个学期。你能相信吗？那是最后一个学期。我本来可以更努力一点，但我没有。我只是太不知所措了。我的未来如此不确定，如此令人难以置信地悲伤，以至于我对自己说，好吧，为什么我要更努力呢？我只是放弃了那一点。[哭泣] 对不起。我不应该放弃，因为很多人没有，而我放弃的事实真的伤害了我。
None of my friends know. I didn't tell anybody. I didn't talk to anybody about it, because it's really embarrassing for me to say that I'm such a quitter.
我的朋友们都不知道。我没告诉任何人。我没和任何人谈过，因为说自己是一个失败者真的让我很尴尬。
What happened to Martha is she saw graduation approaching and after it, nothing. The blankness of her future, suddenly only weeks away, drained the fight right out of her. Her entire college career seemed like a mean joke. She had exhausted herself working twice as hard as most of her classmates to get a UCLA education, Plus waitressing, plus the commute, plus cooking and cleaning when her parents were working, which was most of the time. And for what? She had no way to pay for a medical degree, and no hope of becoming a licensed doctor if she did.
玛莎的情况是，她看到毕业临近，毕业之后什么都没有。她未来的空白，突然间只剩几周，排干了她所有的战斗力。她整个大学生涯看起来像个恶意的玩笑。她耗尽了体力，工作量是大多数同学的两倍，为了得到加州大学洛杉矶分校的教育，再加上做服务员、通勤、在父母工作时做饭打扫卫生（那是大多数时候）。而为了什么？她没有办法支付医学学位，如果她能拿到，也没有希望成为有执照的医生。
There's a very simple solution to all of this. A bill called the Dream Act would offer conditional citizenship to those few kids, like Martha, who grow up in the United States and make it to college or the military.
这一切都有一个非常简单的解决方案。一项名为《梦想法案》（Dream Act）的法案将为像玛莎这样在美国长大并进入大学或军队的少数孩子提供有条件的公民身份。
If they get a degree, or finish their service, they become full citizens. By 2004, the Senate version of the Dream Act had actually picked up 47 co-sponsors. But the Dream Act keeps getting bogged down in immigration politics, tacked onto a bunch of big, messy immigration proposals that nobody in Congress could agree on.
如果他们获得学位或完成服务，他们就成为全面公民。到2004年，参议院版本的《梦想法案》实际上已经获得了47个共同提案国。但《梦想法案》在移民政治中不断陷入困境，被挂在了一堆国会无法达成共识的杂乱无章的移民提案上。
Earlier this year, the Dream Act was introduced again in the House and Senate.
今年早些时候，《梦想法案》再次在众议院和参议院提出。
How would your working life change if you became a legal resident or a citizen tomorrow?
如果你明天成为合法居民或公民，你的工作生活会如何改变？
Wow, the possibilities are endless. The sky's the limit. I mean, I could take any job I wanted. And I'm good at a lot of things. I mean, I could take any job at any lab. I could work for UCLA.
哇，可能性是无限的。天空是极限。我的意思是，我可以做任何我想做的工作。而且我很擅长很多事情。我的意思是，我可以在任何实验室找任何工作。我可以在加州大学洛杉矶分校工作。
Sometimes I think, well, what if it's not enough, that I'll still be unhappy? But the more I think about it, that's not a possibility. I mean, yes, a green card's not going to buy you happiness, but it's going to buy you a lot of peace of mind. It really is. Just being able to work with dignity.
有时候我想，好吧，如果这还不够呢，我会不会仍然不快乐？但越想越觉得，那是不可能的。我的意思是，是的，绿卡买不到幸福，但它能买到很多内心的平静。真的。仅仅是能够有尊严地工作。
Martha went back to school a few days ago, and I don't think her temporary dropout counts as quitting, no matter how she sees it. She hasn't given up hope. Maybe the laws will change. Maybe there'll be a normal life for her here after all. She graduates in June.
玛莎几天前回到学校了，我不认为她临时的退学算作放弃，无论她怎么看。她还没有放弃希望。也许法律会改变。也许她在这里终究会有一个正常的生活。她在六月毕业。
Douglas McGray. He's a fellow at the New America Foundation.
道格拉斯·麦格雷。他是新美国基金会的研究员。
Well, our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself, with Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Seth Lind and Tommy Andres. Music help from Jessica Hopper. Our longtime webmaster, Elizabeth Meister, who created our website, is retiring from the website to go make radio herself. She has done an amazing job thinking through what it is that we would do on the internet in the first place and then making it happen for so many years. I do not know what would be doing on the web without her. Elizabeth, we all wish you the best.
嗯，我们的节目今天由亚历克斯·布隆伯格和我本人制作，还有简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）、莎拉·科尼格（Sarah Koenig）、丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。感谢塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）和汤米·安德烈斯（Tommy Andres）的制作帮助。感谢杰西卡·霍珀（Jessica Hopper）的音乐帮助。我们长期的网站管理员伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister），她创建了我们的网站，她正在从网站退休去自己制作广播节目。她在思考我们最初会在互联网上做什么，然后这么多年来一直努力实现它方面做得非常出色。没有她我不知道我们在网上会做什么。伊丽莎白，我们都祝你一切顺利。
You can see the latest incarnation of our website, souped up now with podcasts and free video, at www.thisamericanlife.org.
你可以在 www.thisamericanlife.org 查看我们网站的最新版本，现在增加了播客和免费视频。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who cannot wait to slip into his monogrammed silk bathrobe, ease into his leather chair and listen to this week's shows.
WBEZ电台对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责，他迫不及待地想穿上他绣有名字缩写的丝绸浴袍，舒适地坐进他的皮椅里，听听本周的节目。
What a treat it would be with a bottle of wine. But stop, that thought is too beautiful.
要是有一瓶酒该多好。但别想了，那个念头太美好了。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多美国生活的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。